guys quick video inshallah tomorrow me
and hijab was meant to be in Florida
um to do a debate we couldn't make it
which we'll find out why obviously after
the whole thing that happened
let's plan on about anyways this is
about Islam it's not about ali or hijab
so we've got two amazing individuals
alhamdulillah who was who are experts
done great job brother Daniel and
brother Jake may Allah bless them
they're going to destroy These Guys
these two filthy scums it's Korea
islamophobes one of them has got a
website called jihados or something like
that but ironically a individual who
carried out terrorist attacks quoted him
in his Manifesto but anyway this video
is a Dua
or like and that we should all make may
Allah make our brother successful Daniel
and Jake may Allah
make the defeat against these let's come
swiftly
and may Allah make the shops tongue and
alhamdulillah the speech clear may Allah
protect them
to eat them and inshallah that you will
see that was subhanallah when the debate
happens that you're going to see they're
going to be victorious easily you know
Islamic as Christianity may Allah also
protect our brothers brother Daniel and
Jake against those backstabbers who are
going to be looking for their mistakes
just to attack them we know who we're
talking about may Allah protect them
against their Pro while they're at the
front lines we are there to Aid them
inshallah and may Allah may Allah not
make us among those who will be
backstabbing them and waiting for an
opportunity to attack them for a little
minute mistake they might make they may
have made or make
may Allah make them successful because
their success is our success our cause
is one and there is no always about ali
or hijab well as long as the job is done
alhamdulillah inshallah and we have no
doubt Daniel and Jake dangerous Robert
Spencer Rashid hamami or uh whatever
your name is after this you and Robert
and Rashid you're gonna need the hamam
inshallah surname is you're definitely
and you're going to need it that's what
I have to say inshallah please keep your
brothers Daniel and Jake in your duas
may Allah keep them firm and make them
successful you've got us behind you
inshallah and we're going to be coming
with a social media storm don't worry
that's it
um take care Brothers inshallah bless
you guys and preserve our brothers
inshallah and the defeat this comes and
send them to the hamam